wow
i don't think anyone out there had 31 to
9. if you did it was 31 to 9
chiefs beat the buccaneers i don't think
anybody would have imagined the
dismantling that we saw
on sunday night yeah we're getting right
into it you guys know why we're here
you've got your tv your smartphone your
laptop whatever however you're enjoying
the program on peacock listening on
siriusxm211 whatever the case may be you
know why we're here you know what we're
here to talk about we're here to talk
about the outcome that no one saw not
even the most ardent buccaneers fan in
their wildest dreams
would have imagined the takedown that we
saw last night of the defending
champions
by the buccaneers a defensive
performance that was masterful an
offensive performance that was more than
good enough
delivering when
needed building a lead that
i i kept waiting chris i kept waiting
that's my big picture thought on this
game i kept one that you know because my
son and i were talking about it well
it's the biggest blowout since 43-8 by
the seahawks over the broncos but that
game was done the moment that the ball
got snapped over the sheriff's head
right right this one i kept waiting
there was this sense this is the chiefs
this is my homes they can find the gas
pedal whenever they want so i kept
thinking it's coming it's coming it's
coming it just never came well they were
outclassed they were outmanned they were
outmatched i mean the best team won the
super bowl there's just no doubt about
that we don't have to really like think
any other way or anything about that
there's no doubt you know added to the
fact that you know it it's the most
complete team in football mike you kind
of just spit it out that's really the
other thing you take away from it
where's the weaknesses of the tampa bay
team they continued to fix those
weaknesses all year long and just
smothered the chiefs in mahomes who
couldn't overcome you know the injuries
on the offensive line mahomes definitely
wasn't 100 running the running around i
mean he's getting surgery on his toe
this week you know the distraction of
the andy reid situation and all that
we're going to get into all of this but
you know how much does that play into
the game i don't know it doesn't matter
the more physical dominant team
won the football game and yeah there was
some parts where we thought oh this
one's still up in the air but all in all
i think we know who was the best team on
the field and it showed yesterday
even though i had picked the buccaneers
to win i was waiting and hoping for
something to happen that would make it
dramatic sure compelling right
interesting and i just think the fact
that i kept
waiting for it in and of itself was
dramatic and compelling because you
think it's gonna happen
but it doesn't happen right that that
here oh oh here oh is it oh oh here we
go and it was just kind of that was the
second half that's right was that whole
until until the math didn't work anymore
for the chiefs and it was amazing the
patrick mahomes thought they still had a
chance up until
the
interception he was going to kill
himself yeah
yeah but but he was doing everything he
could but there was just it just that
is it is it gonna is it gonna and it
just never it never came and one of the
reasons it never came and
our producer matt casey has done a fine
job of outlining thoughts in a very
cogent and cohesive way so i'm going to
try to do justice to that so we just
don't ramble for two hours let's begin
with andy reid the
chiefs
head coach acknowledging it could have
gone better for them and one of the
reasons it didn't is because todd bowles
was on the other side crafting the
defense
listen todd had a good plan but
like i said i
i could have done a whole lot better
putting these guys in a better position
to make plays i mean
you know the
my guys busted their tail and
um
you know we just we didn't
you know it just didn't work for us so
but give credit to todd for for the job
that he did he got us
was this more about what the bucks had
or what the chiefs didn't have that's
the question their tackles because
mahomes was hair on fire all night long
right 400 in the get-go and 97 yards
this comes from seth walter via next-gen
stats or next-gen stats via seth water
either way yeah you know
497 yards of running by mahomes behind
the line of scrimmage before throwing
the ball the most a quarterback ran
behind the line of scrimmage before
throwing the ball
all year long topping mahomes 495
against the raiders in week five so
he had that all night and he had to do
it all night they were on him all night
is it the line or is it the defense well
it's both i mean you know it really is
first off it's todd bowles with a great
plan like andy reid said that's the
thing you're going to start with and
mike you know we talked about it all
last week you can't blitz patrick
mahomes right you can't blitz them
todd bowles is famous for blitzing you
know i go on from brother from another
on thursday go no he can't blitz if they
blitz they'll lose the game that means
there's gonna be one-on-one situations
well you see they blitz what five times
yesterday and i believe
and and i believe like i believe like
three of them were on like the first six
or seven plays of the game so when they
came out mike this was the first great
curveball of the game they they did some
gutsy blitzes early on where i went whoa
temple looks like they're going to blitz
holy cow so now kansas city goes to the
line you know to the sideline and they
try to figure out whoa they're blitzing
us how we're going to attack this and
then it was almost like from there on
out the front four just whooped the crap
out of the the tampa uh the chief's
offensive line mike i mean really it was
an a butt whoop and an ass whoop and
whatever you want to say how many plays
were it like you said well well it's
like how many plays like you're saying
where he got the ball
and you literally thought wait are they
running a screen are they letting the
guys go by them or did that is this a
real pass play like there was a number
of plays where i was like i think
they're setting up the screen wait no
this was supposed to be a drop back the
guy missed shaquille barrett that badly
so i think it's the game plan the
injuries and a front four that was just
foaming at the mouth ready to kick some
butt
you know at one point i thought maybe
they should just put patrick mahomes in
punt formation and do the ultra long
snap to give him more time because as
soon as he got the ball even in shotgun
it was rich it was unreal
and uh and and again
the starters at left and right tackle
were starters for a reason there's a
natural drop off from first string to
second string some cases it's not as
great some cases it's significant
without the two left the left and right
tackles last night i think that that was
a real problem for the chiefs we thought
it would be okay because of my homes but
you know you saw him well now look now
when tony romo started talking about
mahomes hobbling i'm thinking is this
the robert saul a little man a little
old man jog or is he really hobbling but
it did look like his toe was messed up
again last night i i thought it was
apparent on the first drive of the game
i i looked over at my what my wife and
my little boy as you know we were
sitting there watching the game and it
was really on you know what really one
of his first runs where i went okay yeah
he scrambled out and got out of the
pocket but it wasn't the same burst in
the same running there's no doubt and
you saw i saw on the first drive moments
of limping in between plays where i went
uh oh
you know i thought mike and this is
another big aspect of the game talking
about the front four the guys being
injured all of that
you know this is why i did pick kansas
city to win the football game i thought
he would be healthier than the afc
championship game he was not as healthy
as the asc championship game and that
was a big part of the football game his
movement you know that was going to be
the get out of jail free card for not
having the tackles you know i thought
first off you know his foot hurt mike
because we saw very little sprint outs
right there was no sprint outs it's the
best thing to do to protect your
offensive line they didn't do it because
he's got a bad foot so that's a big
thing too and then you know mike his
ability to weave and
you know get around the corner and like
we've talked about so much right attack
the line of scrimmage to now people come
up and get him
then he makes throws behind you he
didn't have the speed to turn the corner
last night or step up in some of those
holes and take off to ever really
pressure the defense and with the
formula of the team and the way they
played and then him not at 100 percent
that led to 31.9 butt whooping
let's hear from mahomes after the game
it took him a while to finally get to
the video conference position as you
would expect in a situation like that
but here he is when he finally did speak
i just think we weren't on the same page
as offense in general um
we weren't i wasn't getting the ball out
on time
uh the receivers were running were
running routes um not exactly where i
thought they were going to be at
um and the offensive line they did good
they they were good at sometimes and
sometimes they they let guys through and
uh when you're playing a good defense
like that you got to be on the same page
as the offense and we weren't today
and that's why we we played
so bad
they beat us
pretty pretty good the worst i think
i've been beaten in a long time
but i'm proud of the guys now they
fought to the very end of the game
you know mahomes has performed well
enough more than well enough in his
three seasons to
be permitted to say whatever he wants to
say whenever he wants to say it but man
there was some stuff in that resp well
he told it
yeah well no no he more than he more
than toted talked or towed it he he was
putting blame on the receivers he was
putting blame on the lineman let's call
it what it is i mean we all freaked out
15 years ago when peyton manning said
well i'm trying to be a good teammate
here but let's just say we had some
protection problems you typically don't
hear the quarterback come out in that
moment and start throwing darts at his
teammates and he did he did look at the
words listen to the words yeah but he
threw darted himself too he said people
aren't happy
right right okay yeah you throw a dart
to yourself and you only throw dart at
yourself as the quarterback we learned
that all the time i remember you got
gruden telling jimmy clausen at the
gruden quarterback camp years ago never
blame it on the receiver it always goes
on you publicly you never blame it on
your guys i'm just i was surprised i'm
surprised i'm surprised i hadn't heard
that clip before i'm surprised that he
went there because again when peyton
manning said well i'm trying to be a
good teammate here let's just say we had
some problems and protection everybody
freaked out i think that that there's
room to say man in that moment patrick
mahomes a different side of him came
through because you usually don't see
that from franchise quarterback yeah but
peyton manning just went right to the
offensive line it was his first comment
peyton manning
patrick mahomes said i didn't play good
i missed receivers then he went to the
receivers and then he went to the
offensive line which he had already you
know had a pre-comment to that to say we
were not on the same page and we were
crappy so i you know again i'm not going
to read too deep into it i think he's
just giving you a good honest answer
that we were crappy tonight we didn't
block so
what point what did we gotta i was all
his fault then that was awesome no no
i'm just i'm surprised i'm surprised to
hear it chris because you never hear
that quarterbacks are conditioned to
never blame anyone but themselves i was
surprised that he said those words
because you you you just don't hear it
yeah i i hear you to repair any damage
you may have done to the extent that
anyone even notices to the extent that
any of the
the linemen especially the tackles will
even be on the team next year how about
run the ball once in a while chiefs the
run was there if you wanted to use it
what was up with that i mean if they're
gonna come if they're gonna be
if they're gonna be
going after mahomes every play into the
backfield don't you take some of the
steam out of that with a handoff from
time to time yeah to a degree but i
think once they got into that mode too
you know the buccaneers would have
stopped that they're able to as soon as
you started to run the ball their
defensive line would have buckled down
but that's not what the chiefs are you
know and maybe that's what makes them go
back to the drawing board and go you
know what
it's just these games like this we need
a little bit more of a threat of the
running game or something like that but
they weren't going to go down running
the ball letting the clock run
and play a game that really was the what
this is what the bucks wanted we knew
that the the chiefs needed to get into a
game where hey the bucks had to keep
pace a little bit and then spagnulo and
espanol spags and everything he does on
the defensive side okay now we got them
and they got to throw a little bit more
the third and longs and i can do the
disguises and blitzes and all those
different things and they can never get
the game to that point you know that was
really the big thing
the tampa bay ran the ball controlled
the clock
and and played past defense but you're
right mike i mean yeah could the run
game been
more effective okay yes but i i don't
think they were willing to go down that
route as they thought that was not going
to be their best way to win a football
game well well right but at some point
you got to realize that what you wanted
to do isn't working the way that you
wanted to work and you've got other
weapons on your team and maybe they do
need maybe they do need a better
presence in the backfield they thought
clyde edwards a lair would develop into
that guy we all had penciled him in for
offensive rookie of the year before the
season even began he had that great week
one performance to get the texans over
100 rushing yards and was never really
the guy after that le'veon bell that was
a waste by them ultimately he was
nothing compared even close to what he
was during his prime years with the
steelers they really need to think about
upgrading in the backfield and using
using
that that guy using that presence
relying on a running game a little bit
more that that's been the andy reid's
story
his whole career we didn't he doesn't
rely on the run game as much as he
should well as long hey as long as
everything else works you don't need to
i know that's all the other stuff is
well that's what i mean you know well
they went they went to have to be 15 and
one so they they were like what what run
game we don't give a damn about a run
game we we got this these guys we got 15
throwing it so that's the way they were
built this year they obviously can go
back you're right mike they might have
to think about that i mean seriously i'm
not trying to deny the fact of the point
you're bringing up it's very it is very
real but i just think with the way their
team was built for this year and how
they play and you're right andy reed and
then back up offensive lineman versus
the best run defense in all of football
i just think they look at that though
and that that's not going to be the way
we're going to win this football game
that'll play into the hands of the bucks
i think where i'm more shocked mike than
anything is
i thought they would really come out and
spread it out
and i thought we would see a better
attack through the short pass game
that's really where i thought i thought
the bucks would do what we saw rush four
and play two deep safeties right we
talked about it on the show on friday i
thought kansas city would be able to hey
just like we've seen ever since that
raiders loss in week five they'll find a
million ways to throw the ball short and
then finally get you to go okay we got
to come up and stop this short passing
game and then they start to hit you deep
and they just never got to that point
they never could really get in the
rhythm of the offense and then of course
they couldn't even protect to throw some
very routine routes down the field and
you know those were their issues of
their football game
and
to the buccaneers credit they put so
much pressure on them early right right
by scoring by getting touchdowns not
field goals by going for touchdowns you
know there was that moment where the
fourth down run and in real time it
looked like the ball got in and then you
never saw a replay angle and then it was
a great defensive stand and and you got
jim nance talking about well there's
never been a 99-yard drive inside bowl
history and and there's the completion
of tyree kill and you think you think
here we go
here we go here we go
so let's go let's get into this whole
moment let's go because this is this
starts penalty bill from here on out for
the most part right
i mean that what
before penaltyville it was punter
shankapotamus
down his leg while crapping the bed
yeah hey hey you know what this this is
this is high-end analytics if your
punter never punts in the regular season
don't expect him to step up and be ready
to go right when when it's time to punt
in the super bowl i mean the guys you
know you rarely use the guy and all of a
sudden he's got a punt regularly in the
super bowl he's dropping the ball he got
lucky on one where he dropped the ball
and you know you're giving the
buccaneers better field position but uh
i assume what you're referring to is
when the flag started to fly as the
buccaneers drove down the field question
well
pass interference penalty or two right
right well that's well i i'm
questionable defensive holding penalty
or two right well that's where i'm
getting to because you're like hey
listen we know the bucks they're the
super bowl champs and we're gonna hit it
all and talk about it all what they do
there but for the game that we wanted or
a competitive football game it was kind
of there at that moment still right to
be had we were all sitting there going
oh the bucks are better they look like
the better team
but if the chiefs can just hang in here
and score a touchdown and just get a
little mojo going and maybe get the
bucks out of their comfort zone who
knows what happens and they get that
stop like you said shankapotamus comes
and then
yes then it became referee time and i i
don't understand it to me mike that
that's to me
where i'm
i was frustrated a little bit with the
football game where all of a sudden hey
the interception
you know and some of the other past
interference calls i want to go
we've watched all these playoff games
and i've seen a hundred of these type of
plays and they were never called and now
we're gonna call them in the last four
minutes of the second quarter
of the of the super bowl and that's my
issue with it i understand a week seven
their past interference all year long
all game long i get it
my problem is in the playoffs it hasn't
been it i mean if they were gonna call
the game that way then the green bay
packers would have been in the super
bowl so that's where that's different
different curve i know but it just got
17 crews you know what i'm saying let's
go back let's go back to the prior
graphic yeah because i think the moment
where it all started to fall apart for
the chiefs
psychologically right that defensive
holding penalty on third and four that
wiped out the tyron matthew interception
where leonard fournette kind of did the
bump set spike tipped the ball right
into matthew's hands that would have
been a huge momentum changer in the game
right and it got wiped out got wiped out
by
a defensive holding penalty
category
right ridiculous like not even a barely
a touching of the jersey like you saw
like a pinch of it get touched like you
just that hasn't been called all
playoffs okay that's question yeah go
ahead question how much of that is no
setting aside the whole it's the super
bowl and a hundred and x million people
are watching and everybody's gonna be a
little more
nervous and edgy and antsy and maybe
quick to grab a flag or quick to do
something unpredictable right setting
that aside how much of it is the brady
privilege how much of it is this is tom
brady and
you know it's the super bowl and he wins
and you know
stuff happens
uh to help tom brady whether it's done
consciously or not i i don't know i i
hate to think that that really happens
but i mean we know it happens i mean
come on we laugh
when he gets thrown to the ground
sometimes the referee is over there
picking him up before he's hit the
ground they're like literally telling
the like so yes there's privileges there
i don't know what to say i felt like
more of this though mike it wasn't about
brady or anything from the way romo
talked to start the game this to me
seemed like a thing that buccaneers
coaches beat into the referee's heads
before the game started that they they
hold they hold they hold and the
referees were looking for it where i
want to go wait but i saw five other
replays on the other side of the ball
where i would go i saw the bucks holding
too and it didn't get called that to me
is what it looked like i don't want to
sit here and get into the penalties made
the difference or not the bucks were the
better football team i know that but the
game was still in a process right there
where it was up for grabs the
competitive aspect of it and the
referees took over in a way they hadn't
the whole playoffs that's where it
bothers me and that's where i didn't
like it and they became the biggest show
on the field for the last four minutes
of the first half well and it's it's a
delicate argument to make because if it
happens in the last four minutes of the
game
it's it's one thing yes but the chi you
know the chiefs had every opportunity no
doubt after that to turn it around now
maybe when they're in the locker room
for the 25 minute halftime they're
thinking well you know we're we're
we're facing extra opponents tonight and
you start to have that sense creeping i
think when tyron matthew blew a gasket
on tom brady that was the first
indication
that the foundation was beginning to
brady went over and started that's the
other thing i'm amazed by too like not
that i you know that's i i hold that
flag in there brazilian
oh my gosh i said i stuck a finger one
guy stuck a finger but that was after
the fact it was after the fact he went
up to him and did this and ran away and
then we're gonna get mad at the other
guy and like come on it wasn't like a
fight broke out right like to me that's
just it's a super bowl it's emotions
there was another one of those called on
chris jones where it was the always
chippy pain in the butt right ryan
jensen who started it with chris jones
and chris jones finished it but how many
times have we seen watching football
over the years the guy who finishes it
is the one who gets nailed because the
officials aren't paying attention to
every guy on the field they miss the
instigation
they see the retaliation that's why it's
so important to not retaliate so you
know they had the full bag of tricks out
they're telling the officials as you
surmised yeah the chiefs hold the chiefs
hold the chiefs hold tom brady knows
which guy to target to maybe light his
fuse a little bit of all the guys on the
defense which one's the most likely to
come back they got them both the honey
badgers yeah let's and between chris
jones yeah and tyron matthew those are
the guys to get to respond and
hey i look i
you you got you got to give credit to
the fact that it was a comprehensive
plan no doubt not just x's and o's right
it was a broader plan to bend
everything their way by the time
we got to half time
you started to feel like you knew where
it was going yeah and hey keeping the
chiefs out of the end zone look i don't
want to
i don't wanna lose sight of what the
defense does that's right we gotta they
kept the chiefs out of the end zone yeah
they kept them out of the end zone the
chiefs for crying out loud the kansas
city chiefs did not score a touchdown it
was significant that through three
quarters they didn't score a touchdown
that had never happened in patrick
holmes tenure with the kansas city
chiefs they had three field goals on the
night these are the chiefs the the this
is the greatest show-offs on turf 2.0
are you kidding me no touchdowns for the
chiefs that that in and of itself
is as impressive a
as impressive as if it was a shoot a
shutout yeah 31-9 is the same as 31 to
nothing when you keep the chiefs out of
the end zone no no doubt mike i mean
you're right
this is the story of the game really i
mean hey listen we're gonna hit brady
he's a legend he's the goat it's
unbelievable but the story of the game
is the bucks defense
i mean are look at the statistics here
this was one of the biggest blitzing
teams in football they had the
wherewithal todd bowles had the guts to
go you know what i've been blitzing my
whole life this is one sunday i can't
blitz look at that two deep safeties 87
percent of the time that just tells you
the butt whooping that was going up up
front between that front four and the
offensive line of the the chiefs they
blitzed like i said it's 9.6
percent of the time i think
realistically the number was five times
and i'm telling you three of them
happened in the first 10 plays of the
game and then they realized wait we
don't need to blitz we don't need to do
anything
we can just play defense don't let up
the big play rally and make tackles and
then like like we said in our text chain
and i thought this was a great call by
you and pete dim a little little uh
little is
is
those linebackers like devin white and
levante david holy crapola batman i mean
they were unreal they were all over the
field once again and you know they're de
facto mvps of the super bowl two for
that performance and nine points and
everything like that
yeah i think if devon white's
interception comes a little earlier
maybe he picks up maybe he gets it yeah
it would have been very hard to overcome
the brady presumption though i mean
brady had three touchdown passes you
know everyone who scored points last
night for the buccaneers wasn't on the
team in 2019. every one of them mike was
not on the team in 2019 right so you
know they they uh they had the
foundation already there with guys like
david and white they both were on the
team in 2019 but once they knew they got
an opportunity
to get tom brady that's when they
started pushing chips into the middle of
the table all in and like where it went
the cool thing the cool thing you just
said too about like the guys that
weren't even on the team last year you
know i heard like uh i'm gonna give
props to ryan clark on espn because i
heard him say this last night he's real
this is a real point this is great
he
those guys you're talking about they're
not there if tom brady's not there
either that's the other aspect you know
you want to talk about what he does on
the field and all that hey listen i
think everybody yeah you know gives him
a little too much credit for what he
does on the field sometimes but damn the
stuff he does off the field and
everything that way and then this
certainly is an aspect of getting tom
brady there at this point he's the goat
people want to go play with them leonard
fournette could have gone wherever he
wanted you know i gronk he doesn't come
out of retirement unless it's tom brady
so that's the factor you gotta factor
into about his work tonight
antonio brown right he's not there if
it's not brady no doubt exactly you're
right so all those guys yeah all this
all the guys who scored touchdowns last
night
are there because of brady now it wasn't
quite the land rush that some predicted
when brady joined the buccaneers it
didn't need to be no
the three guys who scored four
touchdowns last night between them
were in
tampa directly because of tom brady and
chris let me let me spin it forward i
want to spin it forward as it relates to
2021
the salary cap
is expected to be in the range of 180
million yeah we reported that weeks ago
shefty reiterated confirmed whatever d
yesterday 180 there's gonna be a
bloodletting on rosters there's going to
be free agents who are looking around
like john travolta in that clip from
pulp fiction hey the the the money's not
going to be there could have power teams
next year so so what's going to happen
what's going to happen once the free
agents
realize 2021 is a don't get paid go get
a ring type of a year yeah that's when
we're gonna find out
which teams are able to go get the guys
that aren't getting the money that they
thought they were going to get right is
it going to be jason light in the
buccaneers is going to be brian gooda
kunst in the packers
yeah
well right no doubt if you're aaron
rodgers if you're aaron rodgers you are
right now with your phone texting gouda
kunst that's sentiment and you don't
stop you're as relentless as tom brady
was texting his teammates every single
night leading to the super bowl we will
win you got to be ready to go get these
guys who are going to be available and
build out a team that can compete for a
championship and the buccaneers are in
the best position to do no doubt i might
i think it's a valid point and a hundred
percent i mean yeah all those guys like
you're saying
they're all
going to go
to
really a lot of the teams we just saw in
the final four i think because they're
all going to go away okay yeah we want
to go to tampa okay wait campus
rostersville let's go to rogers and
green bay or my homes in kansas city or
josh out because those are our chances
to win a super bowl i we could see some
super teams next year because of that
aspect which will be funny to see but
certainly to like what you're saying
right now yeah i would think the number
one destination is certainly the tampa
bay buccaneers and what they'll have to
offer i mean again there's just the
team's gonna be there the only guy
that's even questionable is chris godwin
and it sounds like they're going to do
everything they got to do to keep him
and even if he's not there
i mean no disrespect by this who cares
they're still got enough good damn
players to go around anyways and you're
right about aaron rodgers in green bay
aaron rodgers yesterday must have been
going crazy going man
if i got to the super bowl we would have
won the super bowl i mean the way the
chiefs looked and the offensive line and
all those issues but either way the
buck's brady unreal unreal what i'm not
ready to say i'm not ready no i know
i still think the buccaneers are the
only team from the nfc that could do
what they did yesterday with mahomes his
foot like that yesterday in the
offensive line the way it was it was a
different chief's team that's where i
don't know if i it wasn't the team i was
expecting to see
hey another guy that the buccaneers need
to worry about before we take our break
shaq barrett oh free agent money right
franchise tag 20 bump over what he made
this year which is going to push it over
20 million dollars in a year where the
cap's gonna be 180 that's a lot if you
can't work out a long-term deal now he
said last night he doesn't want to be
anywhere else it's easy to say that as
the confetti is falling let's see what
happens
mike for the dollars to start falling
because you lose shaq barrett you bet
you better you better hope that one of
those guys that gets squeezed off of
another roster due to the salary cap
depression is a great pass rusher
because you're going to have a problem
if you don't have shaq barrett
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports